- [Voiceover] Anna wants
to celebrate her birthday
by eating pizza with her friends.
For $42.50 total, they
can buy p boxes of pizza.
Each box of pizza costs $8.50.
Select the equation that
matches this situation.
So before I even look at these,
let's see if I can make
sense of the sentence here.
So for $42.50 total, and
I'll just write 42.5,
especially because in all these choices
they didn't write 42.50,
they just wrote 42.5
which is equivalent.
So 42.50 that's the total
amount they spent on pizza
and if I wanted to
figure out how many boxes
of pizza they could buy, I could divide
the total amount they
spend, I could divide that
by the price per box.
That would give me the number of boxes.
So this is the total, total dollars.
This right over here is the dollar per box
and then this would give
me the number of boxes.
# of boxes.
Now other ways that I
could think about it.
I could say, well what's
the total that they spend?
So 42.50, but what's another way
of thinking about the total they spend?
Well you could have the amount they spend
per box, times the number of boxes.
So this is the total they spend
and this another way of thinking about
the total they spend, so these
two things must be equal.
So let's see, if I can see anything here
that looks like this, well
actually this first choice,
this, is exactly, is exactly
what I wrote over here.
Let's see this choice right over here.
P is equal to 8.5 x 42.5.
Well we've already been
able to write an equation
that has explicitly, that
has just a p on one side
and so when you solve
for just a p on one side,
you get this thing over here,
not this thing, so we could rule that out.
Over here it looks kind of like this,
except the p is on the wrong side.
This has 8.5p is equal to 42.5,
not 42.5p is equal to 8.5.
If we try to get the p
on the other side here,
you could divide both sides by p,
but then you would get
p divided by p is one.
You would get 42.5 is equal
to 8.5/p which is not true.
We have 8.5 times p is equal to 42.5,
so this is, this is not
going to be the case.
One thing to realize, no
matter what you come up with,
if you came up with this
first, or if you came up
with this first, you
can go between these two
with some algebraic manipulations.
So for example, to go from this blue one
to what I wrote in red up here,
you just divide both sides by 8.5.
So you divide by 8.5 on the left,
you divide 8.5 on the right.
Obviously to keep the equal sign
you have to do the same
thing to the left and right,
but now you would have 42.5/8.5
is equal to, is equal to p.
Which is exactly what we have over there.
Let's do one more of these.
Good practice.
Mr. Herman's class is selling
candy for a school fundraiser.
The class has a goal of raising $500
by selling c boxes of candy.
For every box they sell, they make $2.75.
Write an equation that
the students could solve
to figure out how many boxes of candy
they need to sell.
How many boxes of candy they need to sell.
Well there's a couple of ways
you could think about it.
They have a goal of raising
$500 and so they want
to get a total of $500,
and if each box is $2.75,
divide the total by the amount they get
each per box and then this is going
to be equal to the number of
boxes that they need to sell.
So this we've done.
This is an equation that
the students could solve
to figure out how many boxes of candy
they need to sell.
Another way you could think about it,
it's 2.75 per box times c boxes.
This is the total amount
of money they will raise.
Whoops, this is the amount.
So this is the amount that they will raise
and their goal is that,
their goal is to raise $500.
So they want this to be equal to $500.
So this also could be an equation
that the students could
solve to figure out
how many boxes of candy they need to sell.